Before we're giving you the example, I want to show you the market maker buy model as well, a depiction of it. Similarly, what you will have is you will have your POI right there. You can see there's a POI. You want to drop down to the one-hour timeframe. Once you have a POI comes into your POI, you want to start identifying or sniping.
or scouting the original consolidation.
So when was the first consolidation before price started moving to
what's your POI?
Right?
So if this was the consolidation, right, I will show you how to
identify them.
Don't worry.
I'll show you the examples.
Tons of examples.
So then that would be absolutely clear.
But you simply look for a consolidation phase one.
And then a consolidation phase two.
This one is not necessary, but it is going to, as I said,
before it's going to make your win rate even higher.
price comes into your pure not remember the time from alignment from daily to one hour to five minutes
So once you get a market structure shift your
Bias or like your setup is gonna be like officially active
Okay, cuz you have a market structure shift if you don't have a market structure shift you are not doing anything
But you are just identifying the consolidation right you're identifying the market maker by model
But once you get a marker, search your ship, one simple thing.
You enter from here, right?
And target, try to target these levels.
However, you don't have to hold till here.
Because we don't know what's price gonna do, right?
We are just only putting the probabilities in play.
Like we have high probability, of course.
But price can simply take out, you know,
like let's say this high over here,
this consolidation and then reverse.
So you have to take partials along the way.
You have to trade your stop loss or you have to go break even at some point.
It all depends on your trading style.
So remember the mitigation blocks, right?
Price if price gives you an entry, right?
You are, you can take longs.
So if there's a fair value gap on auto block inside this mitigation block,
which is an old auto block, bearish auto block, you take your entry from there.
Let's say price breaks through this level, this mitigation block,
this friendly gap on auto block inside there.
You take entry from there and you go there.
Simple as that.
But once you get a market shut to shift, right,
you wanna mark out your range low and this range high.
So now once price comes into your one hour POI,
you drop down to five minute timeframe
and then you start looking for consolidation
on the five minute timeframe around here,
the original consolidation, right?
And then let's say you have another consolidation
and price came into your POI, right?
You then look for a market structure shift
on the five minute timeframe once again.
So that's, let's say price comes into your one hour autoblock
or any POI.
Oh my God, let me disable this arrow.
Just making the chart so messy.
So on the five minute, let's say price comes into
the one hour autoblock or POI.
You get a market structure shift and you have the original consolidation with a second consolidation.
You take your entry and I bet you it's going to hit the take profit.
It's really that simple.
I mean, it's a little complicated, but I'm going to show you the examples and then it will become very simple for you.